[Music]
what do you think about uh Twitter files
what did you see that the stuff
yesterday about Shadow Banning no what
you didn't read it you didn't see it I
read the thing about political parties
paying to have okay so yeah so that was
part one part two was about Shadow
Banning so you know what elon's doing
he's like he's like just taking every
single internal document at Twitter and
like giving it to these two journalists
and being like all right report on what
what was happening because I needed them
to stop talking about how it's not
making money
yeah basically but I mean I find it
fascinating it's super cool because it
really is it's like the first time we're
getting a little inside look into what
a tech company is actually doing doing
yeah and so this is basically about like
you just see screenshots from their
internal tools where like people it you
know has it listed like blocked from
search
uh like so you know they have their own
terms for it but it's basically like oh
yeah we're suppressing this person we're
suppressing this piece of content this
doesn't trend for these reasons see it's
like all labeled
and the reason why and this isn't even
like a political statement at all
um
the reason why I find this interesting
is because you know we
we fall victim to this stuff too right
with YouTube we're always like I like
what is that like on our Channel right
now every single video WE Post gets
demonetized for some reason yeah we're
in that weird and there's no reason
there's no like explicit not no explicit
rule or anything that states if you do
this too many times then but we're in
this sort of black hole where I've been
with my personal channels before I've
somehow gotten out of it but our Channel
right now is in this weird thing where
by default every single video we make
now is demonetized and it's [ __ ]
killing our Channel yep but there's not
there's no rules there's no we don't
know where it's like in this weird
sort of ambiguous area where it's like
we don't know what we're doing wrong yep
and they don't tell you so it's
fascinating to be like to see the inside
of like oh no this [ __ ] is actually
happening yeah
yeah and it probably is at YouTube too
and a hundred percent yeah it's just
like since the videos that we did those
got age restricted and demonetized for
like fetish depiction
and everything oh the okay and every
single video yeah every single video
since then would automatically get
demonetized
and I've had to basically request review
on everything and I get it to go through
but there's something on my channel
that's like Auto no why
just tell us why
that's why you gotta see me on tour
Can't Be censored live yeah
I'm a [ __ ] hero I'm standing up for
free speech [ __ ]
I'm doing what everyone else is afraid
to do
is he texted you the worst DP in the
world calling me during a recording
what's going on what's he saying oh no
[ __ ] way I'm so sorry no no this is
good this is good what do you want to
talk about
um well this is complicated now
say it
okay I'll call you back wait wait wait
that's scary all right bye wait wait
wait Nema what what's a video of ours
that you've watched you've liked
recently say that one more time
what's a video of ours that you've
watched liked recently
um I would say there's not a single
video that I don't like so
all of them everything's perfect I love
it all it's amazing I knew you'd gas us
up that's why I asked yeah please please
keep hiring me love you love your
neighbor call you back
is actually the only one that watches
our content anymore and it's awesome I
know I'm serious when I say I make
videos only for him he came to my DJ set
yeah oh yeah yeah you didn't talk about
that I do it only for him yeah
everything I do
yeah
how was it it was good it was good it
was it was funny
like it was um
it's hard to explain it was like stupid
you know like it was like why am I why
am I [ __ ] doing this like sure but at
the same time I was [ __ ] my pants so
nervous the whole thing was for a video
right it was kind of supposed to be like
you know a little bit tongue-in-cheek
like this is dumb clearly but like it
still was 300 people yeah
staring at me like it wasn't like people
were dancing they were like I came out
on stage and it was like lines of people
just like with their phones out being
like this better be good
you know like we waited in line for this
like and so I'm like [ __ ] my pants
because like what if I forget you know
if I like butchered a transition or
something like it would be embarrassing
yeah
so for the first like 30 minutes I was
just like
just really focusing on like making sure
that it was good and then and then Dylan
Francis came up and we played together
which was really cool we DJ'd back to
back you played
it was cool you played together we
played together yeah nice we played with
each other sorry that's nice yes yes no
we we um pooped back and forth uh we
jerked each other off it was cool
because
like I'm a I'm a huge fan of his music
and I've seen him play like multiple
times at like festivals and stuff like
that yeah pretty surreal for him to be
to get up on stage and be like all right
move over yeah like let's let's do this
yeah yeah you're [ __ ] you're bombing
right now
uh that's good that's great it was cool
it was a lot of fun I'm glad I did it
you know yeah it's good to
I don't know I feel like it's good to
scare yourself like that yeah like it
was it was all a joke until I got there
and it was
people were just waiting like in line
and [ __ ] like that yeah like it was a
show yeah and then I was like [ __ ] this
is way more real than I thought it was
gonna be I just I hope it's good
we'll play that don't play this do not
play that
because I also like I didn't know like
I'm not like a cool guy you know it's
like hard for me to like look cool on
stage like
and I'm also like it's my first time
like do I do I like you know am I
supposed to play into this old [ __ ] yeah
you know
laughs
maybe that one yeah I don't know man no
I'm not sure
you keep going that one that one's bad
the other ones were more I could get in
okay but but I think it's the
it's the right it's the for like it's
very right right it needs to be a little
you know okay gentler yeah yeah yeah oh
yeah yeah yeah I felt that I felt that I
felt that yeah yeah yeah
killed Ryan
you're fired okay
making you say ew is the funniest thing
ever that was too real what you did
we were like just yeah I don't know why
I can put your fingers in your ass like
that that was so not necessary we
understood the bit yeah
we were being
you're just juggling around but you had
to be they're like oh yeah like that was
weird that was crazy dude to actually
finger your own ass in front of us was a
wild thing to do good thing we used like
noise reduction on this because you guys
would have heard it like it was like
oh
is that moan that you played that one
time off the phone oh
that's what sound it was
[Laughter]
Ryan playing voice notes dude
oh
is that a recording yeah
[Music]
this is August 3rd yeah
2021.
Jesus Christ
this is that's the voice I hear anytime
I see the lemon party image
[Music]
you know what I you know what you can't
appreciate until you get older without
that [ __ ] image smelled
old people stink dude yeah like they
can't keep gas and [ __ ] in their skin
like it's just you know it's it's
seeping through
you know more than the smell of say like
because they're they're dry like you
know sex is like kind of moist but those
[ __ ] are dry dude just dry old people
oh yeah totally